[music]
Freddy Flaxman:
We started the dodgeball tournament in 2005. We wanted to create a monster event, that
was the biggest event on campus every single year, and something that would live far after
Freddy Flaxman:
we left and graduated Princeton. So, one of the ideas that we had was to take the most
unlikely people around campus and give them dodgeball nicknames, throw their photos on
Freddy Flaxman:
flyers and just plaster the campus. It was one of those things where once you got people
there, they had a great time, and so getting them back each year became easier and easier.
Freddy Flaxman:
And so the first year, we had about a thousand. The second year, we had about 2,000. By the
third year, we had 3,000.
Daneeka Abellard:
I think that the dodgeball tournament is so popular because it's one of the chances for
lots of people... lots of the different organizations to get together, to rally and have a tradition
Daneeka Abellard:
to follow, because Princeton has a lot of really big official ones, but this is a really big,
fun event for everybody to do together. It's one of our chances to bond with people whom
Daneeka Abellard:
we would never see ever, but at the same time, it's never actual mean competition. It's all in good fun.
Ian Auzenne:
Events like this are important. One, because it allows the students to blow off steam.
There's no better way of doing that than throwing a dodgeball at somebody else with all your
Ian Auzenne:
might, just to get that aggression out. It's like, "Yeah, I just nailed that guy."
It's stress relief at its finest. But it also makes students realize that Princeton isn't just
Ian Auzenne:
a place where you study, you can have a little bit of fun here.
Dave Slovenski:
Princeton dodgeball is a great new tradition because it brings everybody together, involves
the whole campus and is just a great night of fun.
Student:
Just come play dodgeball. It's fun.
Ian Auzenne:
[laughing]
Shasanka Pradhan:
So, what I am thinking now is next year I'm just going to do my homework beforehand, before
the day of the dodgeball, and alot the entire evening for dodgeball, because I just realized
Shasanka Pradhan:
how much fun it is.